[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez découvrir comment un flocon
de neige va vous permettre de devenir
réellement résistants de l'intérieur et
pour cela je les partage avec vous trois
techniques rapides et simples
tout d'abord je voudrais vous poser la
question combien de personnes parmi vous
a entendu cette phrase dans leur enfance
un homme ça ne pleure pas souvent c'est
plus de trois quarts de la salle est en
effet le message caché qu'il ya derrière
c'est un homme ça n'a pas le droit
d'avoir des motions ça n'a pas droit de
ressentir et surtout pas de montrer ses
faiblesses
du coup voilà comment la promesse caché
qu'il est derrière ces sois fort et tu
vas pouvoir toujours le prouver pour le
matic c'est que une émotion ainsi
refoulé va rester bloqué des années et
si l'on prend le cas d'un enfant par
exemple ravalant ses larmes pour faire
plaisir à l'adulte par exemple eh bien
il va garder au fond de lui sa douleur
vraiment au plus profond de lui avec une
pincée de solitude et de non adéquation
de ses sentiments vrais et comme le
disait isabelle filliozat
psychothérapeute adultes et bien cet
enfant deviendra cet adulte pardon tu
seras endurci au point de ne pas
comprendre les larmes de sa femme de ses
enfants et ne saura s'amuser qu'avec un
verre dedans alors je vous pose la
question
étouffé ses émotions est ce que ça nous
fait du bien ou du mal
est-ce que c'est productif ou contre
productif ses émotions à 6 bayonnais
ainsi empilés ne risque-t-elle pas de
ressortir brusquement ou violemment au
moment où l'on s'y attend le moins
comme par exemple lors de l'arrivée d'un
enfant dans une famille et je sais de
quoi je parle quand je vous parle des
motions bayonnais d'émotion réprimées
parce que ça a été mon cas pendant des
années et notamment voilà il ya cinq ans
quand j'étais enceinte de ma fille
j'étais en même temps en train de perdre
ce que j'avais de plus cher au monde à
l'époque ma mère atteint d'une maladie
grave et
là il y avait ciblé un flot émotionnel
quand on suit la ligne à l'intérieur et
j'avais trois émotions désagréables qui
bouillonnait il y avait tout d'abord la
colère vous savez cette émotion qui me
dit qu'elle qu'il y a quelque chose
d'injuste qui est en train de se passer
il va également la peur peur de perdre
cette sécurité maternelle également la
tristesse tristesse à l'idée de ce futur
vide affectif et mélanger à ces trois
émotions désagréables qui bouillonnait
il y avait une émotion fantastique
fabuleuse magnifique la joie la joie
immense à l'idée de donner la vie
j'avais le choix soit de laisser
s'exprimer ces mêmes émotions soin d'y
résister à l'époque j'ai fait le choix
d'y résister pensant inconsciemment
moins souffrir
et puis j'avais cette croyance intérieur
je ne sais pas d'où elles sortent aimé
que si je ne ressentais pas eh bien le
transfert je ne transmettrait pas tout
ce flou et émotionnel raymond foetus
erreur à partir de cette expérience
douloureuse et bien j'ai une quête une
quête intérieure alingue vraiment très
très très profonde
comment enfin savoir comment je pouvais
faire pour me libérer de tant de
souffrances
je me suis donc penché corps et âme sur
les émotions
qu'est ce que c'est une émotion est ce
que ça a une utilité est ce que ça un
message 1
et pour cela je voudrais partager avec
vous mes trois découvertes trois notions
fondamentales des éléments de
compréhension avec tout d'abord la
première notion nous la devons à un
grand monsieur monsieur paul ekman c'est
indécent plus dominants psychologue du
20e siècle
il a travaillé pendant plus de 40 ans
sur les émotions fondamentale vraiment
il a fait la recherche pointue sur les
émotions fondamentale et pour cela il
est parti en nouvelle guinée à la
rencontre des papilles cette tribu
encore isolés du reste du monde sans
aucun contact extérieur et il a ainsi pu
démontrer que les expressions faciales
correspondre à 4 émotions
universellement connu la joie la peur la
tristesse la colère
comme vous le voyez voilà sur ces
clichés de papouilles guinéens
donc pas lekman a donc confirmé
l'intuition de darwin sur l'universalité
des émotions les émotions primaires sont
donc innée est universelle dans la terre
entière le monde entier est le même chez
les hommes
voilà du coup la deuxième motion
voudrais partager avec vous c'est par
rapport à l'utilité
pensez vous que une émotion et une
utilité ou pas et pour cela une émotion
je vais prendre cette métaphore de la
balle et bien c'est comme ce signal
clignotant une émotion ce n'est ni plus
ni moins qu'un signal d'action un signal
qui vous dit d'agir de réagir
si vous avez peur par exemple face à un
animal dangereux et bien la peur va vous
permettre soit de combattre soit de fuir
et le message qu'il ya derrière une
émotion qui est très simple mais ô
combien fondamental c il y a un besoin
qui n'est pas satisfait il faut réagir
agir réagir par exemple derrière la peur
tout simplement le besoin qu'il y assez
j'ai besoin de sécurité
si vous êtes en colère le besoin qu'il
ya derrière c'est j'ai besoin de
réparations soient matérielles
symbolique et si vous êtes triste c'est
ce besoin est bien de réconfort et de
trouver un nouveau sens voilà la
troisième notion que je voudrais
partager avec vous c'est par rapport à
la structure même de l'émotion
et pour cela voilà l'émotion se déploie
en trois temps et imaginez que une
émotion ça soit ce bracelet la première
phase c'est la phase de charge la votre
cerveau charge l'émotion par exemple si
vous avez peur l'émission charge la peur
et le cerveau va donc libérer les
hormones comme par exemple l'adrénaline
la deuxième phase est la phase de
tensions là votre corps est en tension
il va mobiliser son énergie pour pouvoir
combattre ou fuir et la troisième motion
le fait qu'on nous apprend pas à l'école
mais qui est fondamental c'est cette
phase de décharge
là votre corps si la phase d'expression
ou votre corps va pouvoir revenir tac l
état d' équilibre à l'état initial en
mettant la pression à l'extérieur
si la décharge ne se fait pas vos
émotions sont refoulés votre corps est
donc en tension créant ainsi les
maladies des maladies psychosomatiques
est par exemple bernard tu fatigues
chroniques etc
et est ce que ça vous parle quand je
vous dis ben voilà j'en ai plein le dos
j'ai la boule au ventre j'ai la boule
aladin à la gorge un nos tensions ne
sont justes ne sont que un indicateur de
nos émotions refoulées
à partir de là voilà je pose la question
laissez-vous la porte ouverte à vos
émotions
sinon est-ce par peur d'être vulnérable
est-ce par peur de souffrir
est ce un besoin de vouloir tout
contrôler ou est-ce par peur que
quelqu'un prenne le pouvoir sur vous
voilà et là l'idée qui me tiennent tant
à coeur et que je suis en train de
partager avec vous comme le dit arnaud
desjardins c'est soyez avec votre
émotion plutôt que emporté par l un en
faisant corps avec elle
en l'accueillant en la laissant
s'exprimer et en l'écoutant vraiment et
bien l'émotion c'est comme un ballon de
baudruche là qu'il dégonfle
elle va pouvoir vraiment justement se
dégonfler puisqu'elle a été écouté et
comme le disait un psychologue olivier
nuage tous ceux qui ne s'exprime pas
saint-prime et tout ce qui est imprimé
cherche à s'exprimer en la masquer en en
ni résistants en lavant la bâillonnant
nous l'augmentons voyez comme c'est
difficile de nager à contre-courant
on s'épuise à la fin n'est ce pas
pourquoi aller contre nature et ainsi
réprimer ainsi bâillonner l'émotion
persiste de façon souterraine et elles
risquent à tout moment d'éclater à la
face comme une grenade ou sinon sous
forme de manière de manière détournée de
maladies psychosomatiques maladie le mal
a dit comme je vous disais bernard tu
fatigues chroniques hypertension
artérielle etc
voilà donc ceci est vraiment
parfaitement illustré aussi par la
citation de carl jung qui dit tout ce à
quoi on résiste persiste et si l'on va
même plus loin à l'échelle des sociétés
si par exemple le fait de refouler ses
émotions
c'est à l'origine de génocide voire même
de maladies sociales cancer sida
maladies sexuellement transmissibles
maladies cardiovasculaires donc
maintenant parlons solutions concrètes
et pour cela je pense à un exemple un
exemple très parlant de l'école living
school une école innovante où là on
invite les enfants à libérer à décharger
toutes leurs émotions sur des coussins
sur 10 putching ball et les résultats
sont probants et stupéfiants les enfants
sont beaucoup plus heureux il développe
beaucoup plus de créativité et surtout
surtout un savoir être exemplaire donc
par rapport aux solutions voilà je vous
invite à libérer vos solutions vont vos
émotions et pour cela je vais vous
donner trois techniques au préalable je
vous invite à vous isolé dans un coin
bien à vous vraiment de manière à ne pas
polluer votre entourage
vos émotions c'est votre responsabilité
qui à vous de les gérer
pourquoi ce sera quelqu'un d'autre à
gérer vos propres et à interne isolé et
la première technique c'est par rapport
à l'émotion de tristesse là tout
simplement
eh bien vous prenez la boîte de kleenex
et vous pleuré à chaudes larmes vous
pleurez vous pleurez vous pleurez vous
libérer et alors pas de manière
monocorde est pas un
là je vous invite vraiment par la salle
et veulent vraiment à moduler votre voix
vous savez avec des hauts et des bas et
[Musique]
vous allez voir il ya votre critique
intérieur qui va arriver à fond les
galops il ya vous dire où le là c'est un
peu trop théâtralisée mais rassurez vous
une fois que vous contacter cette
émotion de tristesse elle se dégonfle
voilà c'est très très précieux la
deuxième technique c par rapport à la
colère est là la colère je vous
proposais trois façons et vous vous
paierez celle qui résonne le plus avec
vous et tout dépend aussi le contexte
par rapport à la colère la technique du
coussin par aider vous contacter la
colère quelque chose vous énerve où vous
isoler et vous aller libérer sur un
coussin et et vous libérez vous libérez
vous pouvez faire aussi avec plus de son
bien sûr ensuite la technique du tigre
où là c'est peut-être plus au travail ou
voilà vous isolez peut-être dans les
toilettes et je vous fait votre tigres
là vous imaginez en tronc d'arbre et
vous aurez votre visage vous déformez
votre visage et et vous libérer tout ce
que vous avez besoin de libérer fait de
vrais cadeaux à vos collègues en
libérant avant voilà et enfin la
technique de la poubelle très très très
très utile pour les enfants pour
accompagner les enfants à libérer leur
colère vous les invitez à inspirer la
colère comme ça et vous libérer dans la
poubelle et à la poubelle et encore vite
vous continuez à la remplir vous
inspirer voilà ça c'est une technique
issue du sine die qui est une méthode
d'éducation la non violence voilà plus
vous allez libérer votre émotion avec le
souffle le sont plus ça sera efficace
moi non et et enfin nos classes et
élèves la technique des tigres et enfin
si également vous avez une émotion
peut-être de rancune rancoeur vous savez
cette émotion cette haine qu'on garde
sur le coeur à l'encontre de quelqu'un
ça vous est déjà arrivé mais cette haine
elle est vraiment radioactifs dont je
vais vous donner la technique de la
lettre de manière à en trouver la paix à
l'intérieur de vous pour qu'elle soit ok
à l'intérieur et pour cela pareil tout
simple vous prenez une lettre un papier
des fois ça peut être ça peut être un
cahier et vous rédigez tout ce que vous
avez sur le coeur tout tout tout autour
sans lésiner sur vos maux après vous
brûlez cette lettre vous récupérer les
cendres et vous les remettez dans un
ruisseau rivière avec une notion de
mouvement vous voyez pour laisser partir
et après vous prenez quelques instants
pour ressentir ce travail de guérison
d'autoréparation que vous êtes en train
de faire sur vous si des fois pour x
raisons vous n'avez pas temps de
pratiquer ces techniques au moins au
moins ça c'est un vrai cadeau pour nos
enfants respirent et respirer 3
respiration bien profonde respiration
ventrale
donc vous pouvez même le faire en même
temps si vous le souhaitez à l'inspirent
le ventre gonflé sans forcer et alex
pire ou visualiser une paille et voilà
vous pouvez leur faire à l'inspirent le
ventre gronde sans forcer et elle expire
et vous libérer
rien qu'en faisant savoureux brancher
votre cerveau et donc vous reconnecter à
vous même voilà donc pour conclure je
voudrais vraiment vous inviter à vous
ouvrir à vos émotions
en prenant le temps de les accueillir de
les ressentir
et rassurez vous serez toujours vivant
voilà donc soyons à l'écouté de notre
émotion
laissons-la fondre comme neige au soleil
elle essaie de nous dire quelque chose
d'essentiel qu'il y a un besoin qui
n'est pas satisfait et un besoin c'est
vital
c'est le ventre qui parlent pas le
mental voilà quand nous autorisons à
éprouver nos émotions
nous devenons nous n'avons pas à nous
montrer une fort nous le devenons
réellement à l'intérieur et c'est un
véritable cadeau pour les générations
futures que de pouvoir libérer nos
propres émotions et d'accompagner nos
enfants à libérer les leurs quand par
exemple en leur disant pleurs
moore pleure tout ce dont tu as besoin
leader 1 voilà etc et les générations
futures pourront ainsi s'exprimer avec
toute leur authenticité toute leur
humanité et nous passerons ainsi d'un
monde qui semble déshumanisé à un monde
réhumaniser changeons le monde en
commençant par soi je vous souhaite à
tous une bonne hygiène émotionnel merci
[Applaudissements]